if you know you know familiar scenes of
virtual learning it is chaotic in order
to manage online learning for his two
children ottawa pediatrician dr anja
rakhowski scaled back appointments by up
to 40 percent stopped staffing a kid's
covet assessment center and most
impactful he says stopped working at a
kid's vaccine clinic it seems that the
government in ontario is making the
return to school
somewhat conditional on the vaccination
rates of these children well if we
cannot staff vaccine centers either
nurses or physicians because we have to
stay home and take care of our children
the speed at which we will achieve that
vaccination goal in this age group will
just be slower about 20 reduction child
psychologist and mom tess clifford is
also scaling back hours she's part of a
group behind back to school
ontario.ca in its first two days about
23 000 people used it to send a hundred
and eighty thousand emails to ontario
decision makers calling to get kids back
in class we know that the mental health
and academic
and just general well-being impacts for
kids have been huge with each school
closure now managing three of her own
kids at home adrian matheson has since
the pandemic began had to triple staff
at this ottawa family psychology
practice and the need is only becoming
more dire she just closed her wait list
after it reached 70 people the length of
time that they are waiting we just don't
feel as appropriate or safe her practice
is seeing an uptick in all kinds of
mental health and academic challenges we
are seeing a drastic increase in
self-harm behaviors particularly for our
young adolescents and our adolescents
she's even more worried about long-term
effects we may not see for years we want
to get the kids back in school but we
have to make sure when the kids back in
school they can function ontario's
premier again cited teacher absenteeism
as a challenge his office did not
directly respond to questions about the
impact of health care absenteeism there
is emergency child care coming but not
until next week and not accessible to
all there have been no clear metrics for
a return to class january 17th
professionals tell us they're hearing
about hopelessness and mistrust not just
from parents but from kids
donna
abigail beeman in ottawa thank you